[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
looking at the information we have about
the devil so far and how strong he is if
you want to see more black lower content
make sure to smash that like button to
let me know if you haven't subscribed
and ring that notification bell so you
don't miss any new black clover videos
for more anime content including black
clover you can also follow us on
instagram at anime uproar where I'm
posting daily keep in mind there will be
cutting edge manga spoilers in this
video you've been warned now let's get
into it
in chapter 196 we figure out that
someone else is actually in the L Franz
body
someone who turns out to be the devil he
tells us that inside the fifth leaf
resides the devil just as we are told in
the first chapter of black clover when
hasta gets his five leaf clover grimoire
then he says I'm reminded of the day I
used the bond between the mages chosen
by four-leaf grimoires and created the
grimoire of despair so he calls the five
leaf clover grimoire that Auster's using
the grimoire of despair the major's
clearly referred to the first wizard
king and the leader of the elves Licht
who had a strong bond lick was even
going to marry the first wizard king's
sister for me it seems like the devil
made it look like two licked like the
wizard king betrayed him
thus he takes their existing bond and
uses it to plunge licked into despair we
know that the ancient demon had three
eyes
since all elves can grow a third eye as
we've seen with the members of the third
eye from the midnight sun i would assume
that elves become demons when they give
in to despair and the devil is
intelligent enough to make elves undergo
that transformation
he made Lick think that the wizard King
betrayed him and sent Licht into despair
which resulted in the birth of the five
leaf clover that hasta has furthermore
I'd say that along with the grimoire
Licht actually transformed into the
ancient demon somehow the wizard king
and licked managed to stop the devil
from fully resurrecting in the past
somehow half
the grimoire of despair was born the
devil says that at the last moment they
probably meaning the wizard king and
lake resisted
however they the strongest human we know
of in the strongest elf we know of
weren't actually strong enough to defeat
the devil they could only slow his plans
down 5 centuries later the devil is
trying to regain his full power again
except instead of licked this time he is
using Patri he says he is less likely to
have trouble with resistance this time
because he used forbidden reincarnation
magic to corrupt Patri soul with evil
making his mind easier to steal despite
all we've seen so far from the devil all
of his insane Opie abilities that we'll
talk more about in a bit he is still not
at full strength as the devil points out
after he returns to his body he is still
imperfect however in the newest chapter
he says both a flesh body and the dark
grimoire are here and that with these
two things here he can now manifest his
true power and form so now he has a dark
grimoire and an elf whose heart is
filled with evil so he won't resist the
devil as laked supposedly did for now
Patri has turned into a dark elf who is
obeying the devil's orders not only is
he the devil's pawn but you know and
hasta point out that Patri is stronger
than ever now that his light magic has
turned into dark light magic even you
know using mana zone is unable to avoid
dark elf paw trees fast attacks and
hasta is stunned by the power and force
behind the attacks themselves the devil
believes that both you know and hasta
will certainly die fighting against the
dark elf near the end of the chapter we
see a dark orbs around Patri thus he
might also be undertaking the same
transformation that liq did when he
became an ancient demon so long ago
perhaps the devil needs both the non
resisting flesh of an ancient demon aka
a transformed four-leaf elf and a dark
five leaf clover grimoire to unlock his
full power and that seems like it's
definitely likely to happen at this
point so he could very well become much
stronger in the upcoming chapters but to
fully understand the significance of
that statement let's examine how strong
he has already proven to be
in his imperfect form as I mentioned
he's a genius at manipulating people he
treats humans and elves as his
playthings he is able to turn them
against each other and even take over
their minds and bodies and literally
turn them into enhanced soldiers who
will do his bidding as we've seen him do
with Patri in the latest chapter he is
able to take the form of seemingly
anyone like he did with Ron and even
imitate their magic thus he could
potentially use any magic imaginable he
can also use this ability to trick
people and manipulate them into acting
in the ways he wants them to because he
can take the form of someone they trust
imitate their magic to make that person
think that he the devil is actually the
person they trust and then betray them
this can lead to despair and more
powerful puppets that the devil can use
to fight for him he revealed that it was
him who used reincarnation magic to
bring back all those elves so you can
add that to his Opie repertoire and
along with reincarnating them the
process also fills them with evil and
makes them easier for him to control
then there is his word soul magic easily
the most opie magic we've seen so far in
the manga it is similar to Dorothy's
dream magic except it works in the real
world and so his opponents have no
chance of escaping as he says all is
meaningless before his magic whatever he
says happens in reality he can use his
magic to recreate other people's magic
to send attacks flying back to create a
vacuum wall that sucks in magic to
simply make things vanish and so on he
can pretty much do anything by simply
saying iron spears he causes around a
dozen long Spears to shoot up from the
ground and impale Patri against you know
and hasta he creates a storm of blades
that would even impress Gilgamesh the
King of Kings and the magic can be
complicated too with his storm of blades
attacked he mixes it up so that some
blades are magic and some are physical
so that AUSA can't simply get rid of
them all with his anti magic powers
eventually Austin you know both power up
to what appears to be their full power
and charge together at the devil using a
combined attack they take out a small
chunk of his arm
the devil simply says he'll and he's
back to normal
Austin's best and you knows best is not
enough to worry the devil at all keep in
mind that you know was said to have more
natural talent than even licked the
strongest of the elves and he's been
impressing the other elves with his
speed and power since he's shown up
Austin has been keeping up with him yet
both of their combined efforts can't
even get the devil to break a sweat he
then turns Patri into a dark elf who you
know and hasta can't keep up with the
devil is easily the strongest magic user
we've seen so far in the series and he's
about to get even stronger his magic can
literally erase enemy attacks while
allowing him to attack in any way he
could possibly imagine his magic is only
limited by his intelligence and as we've
seen he's an evil mastermind who has
managed to turn entire races against
each other this is one of the most opie
villains i've ever seen in anime I mean
he's the devil after all he treats
mortals as mere playthings let me know
how you think the magic Knights can
possibly hope to defeat a villain of
this caliber and let me know how much
stronger you think he could possibly get
in his perfect form I just don't see how
they could possibly follow up this
villain right now the devil seems like a
human fighting against ants nobody can
do anything to him the big question for
me right now is what's the deal with the
devil inside of Austin's grimoire and
what role is it going to play in the
future Austin still using his magic
powers which leads us to believe that
the devil is still in his grimoire but
why does the official translation use
the devil instead of a devil if there
are multiple Devils I hope this is gonna
be cleared up in future chapters anyways
I cannot see how they could possibly
raise the ante any further at this point
but I guess we'll have to wait and see
and that is it for today's video thank
you so much for watching let me know
what you're thinking right now about the
black lower manga and especially about
the latest chapter if you enjoyed the
video make sure to smash that like
button to let me know if you have it be
sure to subscribe for more black clover
videos for even more black clover
content and conversations check us out
on instagram at anime uproar also falls
on twitch at anime up roar and let us
know if you'd like to
see weekly live chapter discussions for
black clover since we already do it for
seven deadly sins and it's a lot of fun
just a heads up all the links to the
stuff I'm shouting out is in the
description a big thank you goes out to
our epic patrons especially to our pro
tier patrons keelon and the one and only
Gilgamesh and two or three the one tier
patrons those legendary individuals who
stand atop all clans lil lady Kady
Maddie Mac 239 and 817 ffvp thank you
all so much for your support if you get
value from this kind of content and want
to support it you can become a patron
today over on our patreon for as little
as one dollar a month and then your name
will be timelessly engraved in anime
uproar history and appear along these
amazing people here in the future you'll
also get access to our VIP page and only
discord so definitely consider becoming
a patron today as of now we also have
one black clover inspired shirt one of
my favorites on our website anime up for
calm the austell work hard dream big
shirt I love it because I'm into
self-development and I use it to
motivate myself to work hard and crush
it in life if you're interested in that
or any other anime inspired shirts
definitely check out our website anime
uproar calm and I'll put a special fan
discount code in the description feel
free to also suggest shirt ideas you
would like to see in the future in the
comments thank you so much for all of
your support we just recently got our
silver play button from YouTube for
hitting over 100,000 subscribers and
even though we already have more than
300,000 at this point it meant a lot to
us to finally get that plaque it's
something that would not have been
possible without you guys thanks again
and until next time see you space
cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]